when rogan and i they dropped us off on
a glacial lake in canada i mean alaska
we're in the middle of [ __ ] nowhere
and it was so miserable that even the
animals we get up there and the guy goes
i mean the animals aren't going to be up
here i go what they're cold
it's just too miserable they go down to
the lowlands and i was like oh so we'll
just spend five days up here
we didn't see anything nothing did you
guys not catch anything that day you're
cold the whole time you're cold and wet
the whole time
there you go
look at that face brother
all look at that
that's an intense face dude it's cold
huh uh
wet you're wet all the time and cold
yeah you don't look right for that long
joe is shaking joe's shaking his lips
were [ __ ] and his lips were going
yeah he had these giant lips there right
now he was like
you just always called uh
it was fun though right
all we do is laugh all i did was make
joe laughs and who's who's that guy with
you he's like steven
the greatest
that [ __ ] can find you food
anywhere anytime he can find you he can
look at tracks and go out to beaver he
can smell he's you smell that i go
and it smelled weird i go that's beaver
and i was like damn how the [ __ ]
you know what's it what's his name
i think it's on camera where he's like
the ultimate boys yeah he pulled this
piece of fat from behind the eyeball of
a deer that joe shot and sucked it and
he goes put that in your
mouth really sucks and it was a piece of
towel you sucked eyeball i chewed it it
wasn't an eyeball it was the fat behind
the fat behind it it's like a chew it's
like a piece of gum there's nothing on
it it's just like a piece of gum like
that's really dry so what does it do for
you does it give you like because this
is a weird thing people used to chew
these like native americans like it was
like chewing gum you just
yeah but didn't gun gum start from the
hoofs of horses i believe so pretty sure
i believe so this one's okay we should
make this more
put sugar in it yeah and make it pink i
like [ __ ] sugar i like you dude
is that a young [ __ ] nate d as well
that was a good show too bro oh yeah not
bad right yeah i i [ __ ] uh
oh that's a lot of views it's a lot of
views almost a million media is a big
show yeah
yeah i had i actually i think i passed
pretty i did pretty well on this outdoor
test you didn't die no because i watch a
lot of youtube on it i wat i i like
studied it before you went in i just
like y'all continued fire and all that
huh y'all didn't catch anything
no no that's what it's like it'd be so
difficult it always rains all the time
yeah there you go [ __ ] yeah all the time
all the time pass all the time and how
do they decide to fly you guys up to uh
where alaska yep and i said and that guy
dan know he goes he goes we're going to
be sleeping in water and i go let's not
do that is there a way we can not do
that and then there's no seasons i'm
like bear grylls yeah shoot me in the
wilderness when the cameras shut off
flying into the 14th
in the same way but also but also staff
have sneakers in your pocket when you're
up there in the middle of nowhere you
gotta you come out with a seaplane and
if you don't get out there in time
you have to wait till the next weather
window
now alaska can decide you know what guys
winter came early
hell no how long were you guys out there
being i don't know
five years it felt like a long time this
was montana that's where i've never been
that cold
the other place looked a lot colder
what are you guys shooting over there
did you guys kill anything in montana
yeah i got myself a deer you did get
yourself a buck this is where i pulled
quills out of his ass and his legs
out of rogan's yep
he dove off this thing got panicked and
tried to chase the deer and rogan caught
that i ate that deer raw
you hit it wrong yeah did you
it's delicious yeah it's called dress in
it chapelle yeah that's the thing in the
field that's the heart was it the harder
liver
yeah man yeah i'm all set